hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within my
voice has recovered quite a bit
recovered not recovered and we need to
go find medicine for Joe Joe because
he's got a bit of a tummy ache
he's got lodged in his abdominal area I
don't know how bad that is for someone
but I've had major surgery in my
abdominal area and it wasn't too
horrifying so I'm gonna sneak through
here or I'm not it's with the music
don't do the music yet oh yeah over
there I was interesting the way that
happened oh whoa whoa wait that guy's
very eager I don't think anyone's gonna
let me the sneak kill but it didn't work
I think because I warp to another demand
I had that chat first know what they'll
have in there but it was awesome I don't
even care that that guy got a shot off
what in the world I was gonna do a
double stealth kill there but I for some
reason it didn't happen okay whatever
okay there's a yeah Amin Amin Amin I'm
over there
bomb bomb but I'm on anybody you want to
go towards the bomb you want to get
blown you want to get blown bro I guess
like what I could do is I could with a
bottle near him shoot it yeah go near
that bottle it didn't kill you
Wow world of dough you don't see me
like I didn't think you killed him he
doesn't know what happened to him
does he it's no way he wouldn't know
would he know come on Sebastian get
pointed in the right direction okay
won't pass through I didn't know that
was a thing that could happen
whoo as health get over there exactly
what I need okay something about the
camera does not seem right in this
scenario something about everything No
oh okay well that crisis was averted
that gonna drop a oh I thought I was
gonna be able to use it maybe I
shouldn't be so sneaky maybe I should
just maybe this is my mistake trying to
actually do something about this okay
hang on what's this whoa whoa hey whoa
buddy who said you could throw Grenada
is only I can do that in the palm of my
hand okay you know what sneaking doesn't
work for me that's not my skill I have a
very select set of skills and it does
not involve the sneak egde of me so
right now I gotta use all these
exploding barrels I'm gonna use them to
my best ability we're just gonna get
through here as quick as possible so I
don't have many bullets left honey to
very much make use of everything around
although I do have know not what I
wanted Hey look at that
yeah weird huh
[Music]
all right fine that works soon destroy
it then follow now we rollin now we're
cooking with gas come in Quebec Quebec
Oh baby
she did in my arm make me feel good
again go near that bomb he ha he what
car you not dead Oh bond thank you for
the bullets please hold
scarce Gary what do I have in the way of
the I've to regular Poon's he's our
fully upgraded maybe I'll get him back I
don't know how often I get Poon's back
after killing people who nice if it was
more often it seems to be what you're
doing stop mover as oh oh oh yeah I
forgot those just oh my
okay I can't that but what I can do what
do
Oh No I warned you warned you
Oh God Wow I'm such an embarrassment
that was so stupid they're not angry
this is this this went off to a terrible
start when I walk to an alternate
dimension where everything went wrong
that's what happened it's not my fault
I'm not bad and I don't
oh I don't even know what happened to
her
so anyway I'm just gonna relax take a
deep breath and approach this calmly
again because it went awry somewhere
horrible can you custom London the
Hollis cast any lanos days the other guy
no no no Delano
three bones two dead are those gonna
blow okay if the the bomb doesn't kill
them directly then this your wood or the
barrel hey come here oh that one got
away is he gonna blow is this is gonna
burn out
whatever you know what I got one shot
let me take out the sniper do this is
sniper dude it was a sniper do I know
there was Tom Lee incorrectly not are
you okay you need me to hold your hand
there Castellanos the big baby
no don't go backwards what are you doing
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
poop your poopy head stop making me
angry do what I tell you to do god
damnit ah Zagreb ating I better this
part [ __ ] has taken me two minutes now
it's taking me ten minutes
what the deuce is this piece of poop hi
I'm on approach this calmly and
collected there he is
there's the mop Randy come on open there
he goes so I got bullets nope
oh come to pee nope
nope whoa and you're gonna burn you're
gonna learn cuz I don't think you're
dead oh sure all right okay it doesn't
need burn that's a bomb that's about to
go off in my face
I got no bullets left anywhere I'm too
screwed what do I have I got this that's
got nothing I got one handgun bullet
might as well shoot coop in my arm by
now oh that guy doesn't know I'm here
that'll be my strategy I'll actually be
stealthy for once in my life
hey you guys come over right - oh that
won't go off with a crawl right oh oh
even just Castellanos Castellanos what
the [ __ ] for ten goddamn eyes I'm so
angry so angry I'm so angry I'm sorry if
this game would just do what I'm telling
it to do I pick up the goddamn things oh
the way you're doing now are you kidding
me
okay that worked out quite well I would
say can I get out now
all right I've had it about up to here
with this ball I've had it about up to
forever I was already a little stressed
today cuz I'm behind schedule I just got
back from Blizzcon Brendan a lot of you
guys it was totally awesome
I had a lot of fun so I'm very grateful
for everything that's happening and it
was so really cool to be able to meet my
fans and be able to go to Blizzcon for
the first time in hello
[ __ ] I don't need to do he's good luck
Hey yes okay huh
so now all I wanted to do was have a
normal tuck where am i okay I have a
normal time play the fun game for you
guys that I enjoy that's what I'm gonna
do so nice and calm I blame I blame
warping to another dimension because
that was not okay all right so now I
just need to get back and I'm sure that
I'm gonna be able to get back can I have
that
can I have that place so I need to
navigate through here without being shot
to death I assume
okay so if that crawling here can't
crawl the other side
oh oh you don't want to crawl under
there this side god I do not understand
sometimes the way that this game does
okay okay okay okay oh god oh god what
am i why
okay fine
because he doesn't know where I am maybe
didn't Castellanos turn the right way
Castellanos Castellanos come what are
you doing
haha turn the right way there we go
looking fine you can understand what my
problem is here guys
okay so do it get your hands on it get
your grubby little paws on it what are
you doing what are you okay how about
that did he really jump down from this
machine gun to be able to get to me so
dump dump dump get on it get on it
get
I all right Oh righto bride time for a
little payback huh payback's a [ __ ]
stress whose was it up to now don't know
nope no oh god that they down down down
this is a frigging machine gun one
can barely see em soon
okay I guess I oh just a little stress I
had to hold down the button for a little
bit there he's got take control bursts
okay never mind I'm holding up button
screw all y'all
I gotta like score headshots on it or
else something bad
they blow up their own guys and he left
did I do it
whoa was with that what is that is that
a head all right whatever it's cheese
okay whoa I'm on my way
those guys are come in the first place
it would be a big problem women would
even keep them what where they come from
let that back pound humming the poop
what is all this was I supposed to go
back to the machine gun why why was I
supposed to go back to the machine gun
that's a bunch of puppy food
you know
would you
that's right there you am I good now
sex is surprisingly hard to kill with
this thing being a fifty caliber machine
gun do you think it'd be a filly rather
easy compared to the rest of the wimpy
guns that I have these livin on where
are you even what okay all right
yay bloodpack before I could just heal
them with my love but now I need a blood
back let's get out of here fast
yes fastly please I figured what a
minute easier to just keep driving and
not let all of them collect I'm driving
why am i driving driving
what is this road of the Dead this
exactly like run it is row to the
dentist's ice-cream the really awesome
pleasure this is not a bus my ex to say
this game
turn for the weird this really really
not hablo hi hi
all righty then
okey-dokey alrighty then
Kabam I'm sure that bus would still be
intact okay there's only so much you can
blame Oh chapter 12 clear that is a fun
face that is a nice face right there
okay oh boy whoa Nellie
whoa boy easy there with the insanity
okay that actually made me laugh I'm
actually pretty happy about that I mean
as ridiculous as it was I guess you
could call it fun that whole sequence
should not have taken nearly that long
agree you know what I'm actually okay
with it I'm happy about that
Oh me and Jojo bag together all right
even though it's very clear in the last
cutscene that she drove through like ten
more walls before you know that happened
yeah okay yeah I'm okay I'm okay look in
this I did break the back good man no
thank you anymore
alright that's about it kid man no
kidney in oh no wait oh I'm so stucked
in first and then go this way Oh life oh
I don't get to see whatever I was
looking at that's great too
[Music]
Journal of Sebastian Castellanos Mir is
gone I haven't heard from her in days
when to report it but the thing I'm
crazy her car computer some of her
belongings are gone there's no sign of
foul play everything thinks she left me
they keep talking about my drinking as
if it had something to do with Mira's
disappearance except that they're not
treating this as a disappearance they
look at me like I'm to blame for her
leaving but I know she didn't leave
someone took her she was getting too
close to something but what oh okay so
now I get to go back he's an important
part all right some deeper mystery I
guess someone's trying to get to
Sebastian for some reason I have no idea
the story I love the story is great the
story is fantastic
I want to know more about the story but
man this game can't keep jumping at
shadows
what about jumping at real threats you
know the things that are trying to kill
you
cuz that's bad century old mansion
burned to the ground arson suspected
Victoriano estate burns to the ground
arson suspected whereabouts of reclusive
owner unknown you don't know that
I just saved so I don't know I need to
do it again do I have any keys I have no
keys so I'll just save again just so I
can now look at your pretty face if you
are Mira maybe you are maybe you aren't
and then I'll just inject and be on my
way thank you very much lady lady
hopefully things can get back maybe
that's like a point of what's happening
things are becoming more insane in the
game such that it reflects that things
are becoming more insane in this world I
don't know how true that is but hey I'll
believe it I believe anything's this one
I'm just short 250 points to be able to
upgrade my gun more I mean I choose to
upgrade my pistol because I guess what
they give me the most ammo of by now I'm
at a struggle to keep ammo in anything
so I might as well do the things they
give me the most stuff who knows if
that's correct
where am I even going so obviously I'm
supposed to go down that way but let me
go around the other way first cuz I
actually didn't get a chance to look at
whatever he was trying to get me to look
at shotgun shells that'll do good could
I oh I don't know that set for that one
I'll go back to the old pump action
because I like that anything else around
here that I needed anything at all speak
now or I'm gonna move on alright moving
on
is that breakable there we go ah some
bullets right there yeah yeah yeah
alright let's move on Joe Joe you got to
forget her Kidman's gone bruh goes green
before acid this was green before I
promise you that
okay then Bell's rings range are oh just
the stuff I needed to be able to upgrade
but just a little too late nothing there
all right let's move on okay
what do you got from a game what other
monstrosity could you possibly throw my
way I'm ready for anything at this point
[Music]
well there seems to be a lot of barbed
wire it seems to be a lot of barbed wire
on the door the schemes unnatural felis
with the substance seems to be
permeating the different areas of the
game or different areas of the world are
we any closer to that lighthouse what
could cause this much damage someone's
messed up brain subway sticking out of
the ground but look how its positioned
if we can get over there we might be
able to use it to get across bowl tall
and Bowl let's just concentrate on
getting out of here okay thanks good
advice Jojo we're still no closer to
that Hospital God why did we run away
from it in the first place
it was the only safe place to be Oh Gabe
bullets anything else not that I can see
let's jump on this precarious and very
dangerous obvious gonna break thing can
I jump on oh I need a chute that okay
I thought I was supposed to jump on it
like a goober no just shoot it out it's
fine it's so fine baby this whole game
is so fun don't play with my emotions
there no of course dad why not hold on I
think I see another way down I'll meet
you on a lower level really cuz I didn't
see you another way down and I was just
up there with you he could have made it
you could have made it easily on that
ladder and jump over why would that be
risking it our best to split up you know
how these situations are dammit first
kid money now now judge oh that's okay
whoa whoa what is that
oh it's my body whoa whoa looks that guy
like I found a friend yeah all right
let's go
give me some wah wah wah give me that
brand energy want some of that brand I
thought this guy was done for good but
it looks like he's back again which is
good for me because I'm really hoping
that the creepy moments are gonna come
back how about a little bit of my fill
of insanity at this point it keeps
giving me all these matches but I don't
have enough opportunities to use them
because I can't burn anything until
they're already on the ground and if I
get close enough I might as well just
stealth kill them okay so that guy's
just walked through the fire and the
flames I'll be smart and go the opposite
direction hey hey hey hey you want to go
through there totally I know you do
maybe there was some way that I could
use the wine to burn people because I
guess you know since it has alcohol in
it might be flan oh well that worked out
effectively can I burn that guy now cuz
I'm assuming he's not dead yep all right
all right speak and ye shall receive I
got an opportunity to use exactly what I
needed
yes please delicious supplies I have not
had yet nearly enough of them give give
give give give give give give give me
man the wonky controls I could forgive a
lot but the wonky controls kind of kind
of start [ __ ] with me around now
route now
well I can't criticize I can't even talk
so that's a Rubick
that that's a shadow ruvik oh ah what am
I supposed to do about that he takes
like a bajillion shots and he summons
tentacules delicious delectable dental
goons move along making my way downtown
walking fast movement passing the ball
bound so you get distracted
I'm gonna go disarm your trap I'm gonna
go disarm your [ __ ] and have a good old
time oh wait no oh [ __ ] I can't get
through here I need to oh do I need to
showdown with this guy oh that's problem
you didn't see nothing
I'm hoping that Rubik gonna go the other
way is to need to be able to get up on
this guy you can't see me right oh come
on what is this baloney malarkey
malarkey
oh come on account for [ __ ] me oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] me I didn't oh god damn it I did
so bad whoa okay that's bad do I have
anything else god that guy where did he
come from how did he spot me oh this
really bad
whoa whoa whoa whoa you gross very gross
now I'm out of here
screw you guys I don't have any health
oh I'm out of here oh oh [ __ ] works
you want some huh Rubick clone
just brighten your face come on
[Music]
that's not okay did he fall down he fell
down you go boom can I burn him I don't
know
here we go burn burn burn burn burn up I
don't care Rubick clone get burnt I did
it somehow somehow I did it is that a
place to hide it's okay I don't know
what happens like every time I try to
sneak someone somehow comes running at
me for like no reason there was no way
that guy should have spotted me and yet
he did somehow he did keep running
around this corner like a goober I'll
take your supplies from this trap though
why are they making traps an acid shower
that would probably kill me pretty
spectacularly it might be nice to see
but I don't have time to go back
oh hello is that another ruvik clone now
how did they not spot me I was out in
the open
literally out in the open who's no way
that shouldn't oh man
okay is there any way I can like get
through there or something or maybe I
cannot distract him a bit get them to go
over that way maybe I don't know I don't
even know if they were distracted by
that I don't know if this is good idea
here I go anyway okay I really gotta get
through here I roll
I can't disarm that can't risk it can't
risk it okay now the bottle of wine good
I can drink all my problems away am I
supposed to go down there
it looks like a thing I could go down
the supplies yeesh I guess not
they've got to find another way down
what was that oh don't tell me I could
have come in through here the balcony I
didn't even see that okay that was my
bad I should have known that god I
didn't see it I don't see a lot of
things in this game either because I'm
panicked spinning around I had things
chasing after me or I'm just generally
being a doof more often than not it's
the ladder that's interesting
go for that please okay I see you over
there don't know how to get to you I
can't go down that way either
ah what the [ __ ] oh my god I don't need
to know I didn't need to burn that sorry
I didn't [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm so boned I'm done I'm done I'm done
something's coming up I'm a oh god it's
a Rubik now why now
[Music]
that hurts that looks like it really
hurts okay that that's a thing god
damnit I I don't know I didn't just run
away I should have just run away I tried
to disarm and I forgot that he was gonna
do his thing his happy hand dance where
am I now
oh no my all the way back to the
beginning
Rubinstein boopin stony oh oh my life my
life is filled with pain don't you come
over this tripwire you're good you'll
feel real good come after me bro
hey look it's me duh hey come here
now they don't want to detect you run
quickly no can't be
not Jeremy no not Jerry now I got the
Rubik clone he's gonna go on that room
and then I'll be able to sneak in behind
him and hopefully I'll be able to
stealth kill the guy on the balcony
before the other guys spots me and then
I'll be able to deal with it in that
order
I'm assuming I can't stealth kill ruvik
that would be way too easy
nope
what do you know what do you do come on
with this baloney no not okay not okay
not okay now okay okay
I'm dead why did he come back why did he
turn around this is just because I got
too close buying them and then how am I
supposed to sneak up on anything
I'm just running you know what [ __ ] it
I'm running for it I'm running for it
screw all this noise
growl y'all scroll y'all stealth is not
my forte therefore I shall not try at
that there are better ways if I could
just pick up things that I need there
better ways hey there how's it going
friend come after me bro
excuse me while I craft up some stuff
you just you do your thing
yep battle ooh
oh you all right there buddy you're at
their friend oh yeah goodbye I Rubik
hope you have fun in hell oh look they
didn't hear me
oddly enough somehow burn it
[Applause]
that guy is going to be pinned to a wall
so I don't think he's gonna be getting
up but just in case okay that's a bomb
Oh
can't go down that way there's another
block I got she at guns I'm gonna use to
my advantage
get it go through here that guy's gonna
get stealth killed maybe nope
whoa okay then get blown burnt did
anybody else hear that where's the other
Rubik oh there is well no that's not
Rubik whoo hey who are you go through
the trap yeah do that
no it doesn't affect him kind of unfair
crap is this baloney burn burn burn baby
burn
I don't even know why I try this point
it's going much more smoothly shotgun
shells SARM that get some parts get
those anything else in here that I need
grain jars and I'm out air what the hell
guys
what the hell game stinking is the exact
opposite thing I should be doing I just
got a checkpoint oh my goodness can you
believe this ha ha oh man oh maybe I did
it better maybe I did it better blasting
people making all sorts of noise hey
don't matter it's all good
you're in the back your seat belts are
squished down those seats you'll never
find him okay who's around that sounds
like big guy oh hey there's big guy
so it's good guy doing oh yeah you want
tussle you want tussle friend oh I'm not
ready to tussle how fun
I guess that's this your new hammer
ornament huh it's gonna be carrying that
around with you from now on
looks good it's good touch like it go
mommy just disarming stuff getting your
supplies since apparently these don't
affect you guys anymore wonder why that
is why don't the bombs affect the dudes
little Bowl don't my me how's that you
know I think if I dive through that
thing fast enough if it was real life
I'd be able to get through that before
it actually triggered I didn't even get
this statue there was a statue with the
key in and I couldn't get in time
because I was blasting through there oh
well that's the price I pay for actually
being able to get through ha ha ha ha
can I crawl through there no I cannot
okay go anyway where am I going now
this is not correct
ooh that's creepy Oh what is with that
oh yeah
creepy ass painting whoa I almost didn't
see that okay we're safe now and we're
back to the beginning okay so we need to
go through there I got all the spare
items though all right what do you got
for me game whoa wait wait wait wait
before I go through there
what okay never mind go I'm going
through there right now right now right
now what else you got for me game huh
bring it on gonna lose it now thought
you could add some brain juice from me
why don't just give me one big jar why
you give me three small ones and another
checkpoint now I know I'm just that good
I doubt she'd still be in there but
knowing this game maybe she will be you
never know I can't go down that way must
go this way don't thought oh hello crow
should I kill you now you have a fun
life enjoy the destroyed settee enjoy
the crumbling of society around us
well Adams got me that guy's still alive
ooh super mags three of those those will
be useful for something I'm guessing I
need to save those for a boss no no not
that way no then which way am I supposed
to go about the room what is with that
anyway this is a wired haven't you
figured it out yet yes tormenting others
has to let them know he has the upper
hand the bait gets his victim all worked
up his uh no holy traps it was happening
to me I couldn't see what was going on I
could see it but I couldn't turn back I
had to know I had to know the truth and
he knew it
Oh Castellanos
lady level with me am I going crazy if
one wishes to survive
they trust okay well that'd be nice but
I haven't had a choice also should I
trust you
that's a big question that I have in my
mind I don't know I can't open that one
oh yeah because my room yeah
all right even no news stories something
on the board here though missing crimson
City police detective Joseph Oda
disappeared while returning home several
eyewitnesses claimed to have seen him
searching crimson city for someone no
that's interesting why are these people
all disappearing and I'm hearing reports
about her these reports from the real
world or are they just in this world
we're we all disappearing a long time
before this actually happened is that
what's going on here cuz I've been fust
this doors open thank you for opening
honey straight to the upgrades I like it
no foolin no fussing no muss
and here we go again oh I could either
upgrade my life which might be nice but
I could also upgrade my dabble its to
200% I like that even better fully
upgraded on the damage gonna go all
fully upgrade my trusty sidearm soon
enough
ha boop boop little lady don't tell me
how crazy I am I already know I already
know great brain juice in here just when
I needed it hey y'all ah where am I
going now all this doors open now I see
how this is thank you for that I needed
it I will use that now wherever did I
not be oh I didn't actually pick it up
Wow how stupid yo boo that feels good
and carrying on more brain juice they're
just leaving brain juice littered
everywhere now I wonder if they just
know well there's actually a lot of
health kits I don't know if I should be
grateful or worried hello what you doing
over there buddy whoa so uh should I be
worried about that guy over there is he
setting traps for me are you
more craftable maybe I can mix up some
cool stuff now I could use oh well oh I
can make another explosive bolt the some
of those that I like more than others
this time I my buddy is still few wait
those lights are on that guy I probably
don't want to sneak up on him not the
double combo what a bunch of malarkey I
knew that was gonna be Ducie tree oh no
no oh okay I thought that was gonna get
me okay now this is being a prick now
it's just giggling yeah and I'm gonna be
I'll be back there in a second it's
gonna make sure nothing of air that's
been in okay I'll go this way I really
don't know if they're like choices of
directions that I could go like if
there's alternate possibilities of
places I could be your things that I
could do as a loss of lies this way so I
guess I'll trust it rain energy no a
little booze no where am I going
what am i doing ah oh oh I see okay was
there one last thing
yup but nope okay wait what
ah nope it's also false alarm there we
go map fragment I knew I was gonna miss
something okay now that I got all the
goodies I can carry on my way down into
this place what have you got for me now
what cruel supplies and jokes do you
have for me I meant to say surprise what
a sense of lies
okay more goodies craftable x' i'll save
that until i know what i need for a
certain situation if i need to craft up
certain doodad
they're giving me a lot of brain juice a
lot of supplies going on there I still
wasn't ready for that that startled me a
lot of supplies I don't like it I don't
much care for it
Joseph why don't you call out Jojo how
do you see even think that could be him
guys gonna get me killed
I really miss getting a lot of sniper
bullets that was a thing that I enjoyed
I'm ready for whatever you got for me
let's do this come on it's obviously not
gonna be Jojo you've been falling around
box dead for a while yeah hey bullsh
yeah ding ding ding ding ding let me
make some more noise
let me just sing at the top of my lungs
walking through the kitchen oh I hope a
monster cowbell so my video
it is Jojo okay bye oh he's got the
friend after him that ain't good oh hi
Rubik yeah I know you know I'm here
well that was unnecessary oh god now
what
well obviously the power without if you
couldn't tell and what I'm trying to say
is this reminds me of scene from
Jurassic Park it got really creepy in
here stop spazzing out about the disarm
something weirds going on now oh oh I
almost set
oh god that's a demonic Roomba Oh give
me give me give me give me give me
oh that's a bad room bedroom apply fire
kind of supposed to be a fire
extinguisher
Oh st. good Oh God Oh why what why are
there traps this is gonna be impossible
this is gonna be impossible also in what
weird scenario was there ever a
situation right
what situation was there ever where
there was a door where I could actually
kick it open and affect the people on
the other side of it I don't know
also I don't know what I'm doing so
there yeah I know
demonic Roombas this shit's bad yo [ __ ]
is real bad so that's a trap over that
way
I know how oh oh it's just period all I
see it now I see it yeah I got it
disable this whoa okay it's periodic
periodic periodic periodic oh go go
yah yah yah yah yah yah no no whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Tama
good oh oh come on that wasn't even near
it
yeah act like you went through every
pore of my body oh this game oh this
game oh this game oh this game oh this
game exactly the beat me this game is
not gonna break me I shall break it like
little thing that can easily be broken
in whatever language I'm trying to mimic
so anyway I'm just gonna assume that the
one thing there actually might not be
periodic this one here is it's
definitely periodic I can go through it
right now okay so the other one I really
don't know about that one
let's watch it for a bit while I tried
to design this thing whoa wait wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa easy there easy
there easy easy boy easy boy easy boy
you need to clean somewhere else I'm
perfectly clean over here fire go thank
you
hiiii no no no okay oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh goodness oh god oh god okay
it's bad what do I do do I go I'm not
going through it hi this disaster
incarnate maybe that's telling me that I
can use the lightning things to stop
that one fire there also trigger for a
trap
you did this on that come on hurry hurry
hurry fires coming come on all I need to
crawl through there oh it does go all
the way down I need to crawl through
there oh I didn't get that okay I didn't
get that at first I get it now I get it
now I get it now I get it now I got it I
got it I got it I got it
god I gotta gotta gotta gotta get it I
don't even need to disarm those do I do
I need to disarm those I don't okay I
get it I get it I get it again is gonna
get the kitty kitty kitty kitty I get it
I get it again
I get it together okay so I need to go
through here this is where I need to go
whoa
so that's going backwards whoa wait whoa
just get out of here rumba roma roma
room rumba rumba somewhere else oh wow
I'll fire you please coach me that's
that ain't good
that ain't good I'm crawling it won't be
able to go oh my goodness
well that's bad
okay okay we're fine zoom through oh
yeah yeah no no I'm fine okay there's
the disarm over here just got to do that
[Music]
by you in this one spot hey yeah yeah
yeah you're not supposed to be smart
you're supposed to be very disarming oh
no no no no no no no yes yes I'm out of
here baby I don't care what Oh God why
no no
[Laughter]
Boop poopy all right you know what I
can't take it I'll take care of this
later
I don't cutting a little early let's
just I got things to I got what I gotta
do today I don't want to give this
episode up boy I'll figure out later so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching I'll figure this out in a
little bit oh I don't know click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always see you
[Music]
can't see everything's going crazy other
wanted I think we should you know this
is the great step yeah
[Music]